I completely forgot to start the
recording button the record button
welcome to this video and we have what
is this actually I'm very weird opening
hmm some I don't really know what it is
some sort of weird Vienna game type of
type of stuff now probably coming from
1g3 ok let's see what happens maybe d
force is at DM okay i can i can give up
this Bishop to establish better control
over the dark squares
yeah c-5m looks like like a
transposition into some sort of Sicilian
close Sicilian okay yeah he probably
wants to wants to play with c3 rook c8
was to protect see file because this was
my my plan now playing in the center
opening up the center in a situation
where the night on d1 and the bishop on
you to look look somewhat clumsy okay I
can take now on you for not bad I can
also play d4
that's probably both both okay I take
you will wreak you recapture with the
power now yes one step Knight to g5 they
are strange strange brew the treatments
myself sorry a strange position where
he's got the knight on d5 and I got a
good night on e5 no heart to heart the
same widest certainly ok here d5 st5 is
a good square of course mmm can i play
93 and snatch this pawn it's a bit
cheeky especially considering that in my
play will be one then and take on b7
hmm what I don't know is where to where
to put my my queen here 97 chickens also
somewhat somewhat annoying I really I'm
really unsure what to do here so I'm
going for this direct play let's also
see for here maybe see form yeah c'mon
let's establish this and then be five
maybe that's an interesting way to play
okay is it taking here can I get rid of
this night somehow 97 yeah come on let's
let's try that get rid of this piece and
if I take on d5 then also see three
becomes weak I really must make sure
that the knight on d5 is going away
terribly annoying piece last warning i
never played the sky to see the name in
there you only think you know okay
hmm interesting interesting move and not
exactly a move that I had since in any
way anticipated hmm okay
mmm but that's really strong cannot take
on c3 now that's sound quite a big
problem
yeah that's really strong what can I do
very strong play you you want the spawn
in this way I really had no ain't
nothing good I mean this is not exactly
a dream giving giving up the pawn like
that I still have decent pieces and c3
as a target that stood it's obviously
nothing I had planned
yeah maybe I can get into Queen and
night against Queen and bishop okay time
morning want to play before really not
not ideal at all hoping for for roots
III to happen we should be five maybe
okay yeah I have some counter play but
it's nothing great
okay starting to get slightly more
optimistic about that not not for we
know anything but this is at least some
counter play my bishop is clearly better
than his okay if I can play Queen a
queen e5 or queen F form to really get
in down you know the material is not
mattering here this is just just
dangerous now for him 35 seconds though
that's Jack that's made into buddy I
completely lost control over this
position quite strange he said says slip
yeah of course I was so clearly worse
take back a plastid take back and this
is a five-minute game I don't give a
table design I heard no offered John
McHenry okay mother requested there come
on reply sleepy head back except me come
and do that take back your bev your OC
anyway check
the problem is I've got 30 seconds the
position is already already better for
black at least I'm not worse grah a
third check check me I mean at all how
many capex do you wanna meet it's just
just tricking off white I'm not worse
iam um I was outplayed that that's clear
with night before this was a strong move
I didn't see that at all night before
hmm yeah very very interesting it's a
very strange position with the night on
d3 and the knight on d5 it's clear I
didn't want to take here I look be one
Andrew p7 looks very awkward so this one
b3 b5 this looked very normal now you
went here and here maybe I need some
improvement something that makes night
before less of a problem yeah that's not
it I mean here it's clear that that I'm
in trouble I'm just losing this pawn I
haven't seen this at all I was only
thinking of while capturing mostly on c7
but night before is much stronger yeah
no I'm the porn down for pretty much
nothing
yeah maybe you should play e5 I don't
know here I sort of thought that ok I
have no big improvement here anyway so
go to the opposite colored bishops and
here I was really expecting him to play
for something like a 45 and not this I
mean this is this is not a good decision
I think because I get the play on the
dark squares maybe a computer defense
this mercilessly but form for a human
player this is already already a bit
tricky ganti I don't I don't really
think I have any problems anymore yeah
the computer has started to turn turn
towards black until you clearly so he
can he can get the pawn there it's no
problem black is clearly better him he
already stumbled into the maid check
various ideas yeah I didn't want to draw
mate oops this was a bit a bit quick
check I was of course he must he must
move the the Queen back and then I'm
just continuing here and then maybe he M
it's it's it's just very very
uncomfortable for wide to play I always
have the threats and he cannot really
advance the pawns you know something
something like that is just very
annoying to play the computer is giving
like a pretty substantial edge probably
black is winning pawns back and keeps
the attack some somehow this is the the
main line of the of the machine check
check then just just something like that
walking King g7 yeah it's it's not much
fun I'm totally blocking all pawns and
maybe long run I can even push the same
what is not moving any porn ham yeah
very very bad position for what okay
thanks for watching